Love is blind.
We already know that.
It knows nothing about looks, languages, and even less, about distance.
Many have their loved one far away,...
...in another neighborhood, town, or maybe in another province,...
...and they have to make long trips several days a week at any given time...
...just to be together.
Maybe somebody moved, or summer love survived the summer,...
...or romance had ceased to be virtual,...
...or simply love and their reasons wanted it to be that way,...
...people that walk under a burning sun,...
...or spend hours on a bus, train, or packed subway, and sometimes altogether.
It might be 40 degrees or five below zero.
It might be raining cats and dogs or snowing.
Weather doesn't matter.
And we're not talking about fantastic stories.
These are real people.
Love and the will of being together are stronger than all those obstacles...
...including, of course, not having a car.
We believe that love as big as that, that strong,...
...and that goes beyond any distance deserve some recognition.
That's why this Valentine's Day,...
...if you have a love story without a car, share it on our fan page on Facebook...
...and win the chance to celebrate with a Volkswagen for you...
...to pick up your loved one whenever you want...
...to go wherever you want together,...
...because the best thing we can do to celebrate love is take it everywhere.